morning Boris Johnson on the move this
morning but there's no getting away from
the inquiry demanding his covid
whatsapps raising questions about the
new prime minister today in Kent on a
health visit this is Chris with a man so
familiar to the pandemic but Rishi sunak
I'm willing to confirm what he'll share
with the covert inquiry I think it's
really important that we learn the
lessons of covid and that's why the
inquiry was established and we want to
make sure that whatever lessons there
are to be learned are learned and we do
that in a spirit of transparency and
Candor government has cooperated with
inquiry tens of thousands of documents
have been handed over and with regard to
the specific question at the moment the
government's carefully considering its
position but it's confident in the
approach that it's taken but approach
today became a bit confusing in April
the covert inquiry requested from the
government all of Boris Johnson's
unredacted whatsapps and Diaries over a
two-year period at the height of the
pandemic in May the cabinet office
responded arguing that much of that
material would be unambiguously
irrelevant some of it potentially
personal and private the covid chair
though remained Resolute but allowed
today's publication deadline to slip
until Thursday baroness Hallett also
revealed that the inquiry was informed
that the cabinet office does not have in
its possession either Mr Johnson's
WhatsApp messages or Mr Johnson's
notebooks
this is all quite curious the government
don't have Boris Johnson's documents but
Team Johnson say that cabinet office
officials went to his office to examine
his notebooks in person they say that
Boris Johnson is very happy to share all
of the relevant information so why then
is the government willing to risk a very
public battle with the covert inquiry
there's lots of public inquiries but
this was I think quite unique whatever
the truth there may be something in
keeping the documents out of sight for
the Prime Minister he was Chancellor
throughout that process and there will
be other ministers who are still around
the cabinet table who will have concerns
as well but these should be messages
about government business it should be
in the context of this unprecedented
thing happening in the UK and all around
the world that nobody really knew how to
deal with do you think they're trying to
protect Boris Johnson I think there's an
element of that yes because for the
Prime Minister his support base is his
MPS he hasn't faced a popular vote the
members did not choose him so you only
have your MPS to draw on and there are
those who think dangerous precedent is
being set the issue of relevance that's
important this committee this group have
to set out the relevance of their
requests very specifically what are they
after why are they after it we need to
understand what their purpose is in
getting it otherwise it just becomes
another fishing trip you know there's
something interesting will pop up what
are the WhatsApp messages tell us about
your behavior during lockdown
do they further impugn your integrity
sir
is your political career over Mr Johnson
that not yet clear what is clear is that
Rishi sudak's Troublesome predecessor
continues to loom large over a prime
minister trying to move on alifoldsku
Sky News Westminster